[MUSIC PLAYING]
KHELAN BHATT: Good afternoon.
Are there any beer loves,
beer drinkers in the house?
All right.
So it's almost that time.
My name is Khelan Bhatt.
I'm Global Director of Solutions
with Anheuser-Busch InBev.
We are the world's
largest brewer.
We are responsible
for some brands
that you may have
heard of and may love--
Budweiser, Stella
Artois, Corona.
But we actually have 500 brands.
And beer's a very local product.
I'm going to talk to you
today a little bit about some
of the innovations
we're doing, leveraging
artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
Joining me is Salil Amonkar.
He's with Pluto7, our
trusted partner in this.
SALIL AMONKAR:
Thank you, Keller.
KHELAN BHATT: So let's get
going through the agenda.
We're first going to talk a
little bit about why we're here
speaking with you today.
We're going to talk
about our supply chain
and how we're trying to
innovate, because beer,
it's a very resource
heavy product,
the margins are very slim.
Beer does not like
to be transported.
It does not like to be shaken.
It does not like to be
exposed to lots of light
and heat and other things.
And so it's really
important that we're
very lean and efficient
in our operations.
We're going to drill into
our production pilot that's
happening in Newark, New Jersey.
And then we'll talk a
little bit about the origins
of our partnership with
Google Cloud and with Pluto7.
Then I'll hand it over to Salil.
He'll get into a little more
of the technical details,
some of the criteria
and the success,
and what we're
really excited about,
and how that plays a role.
We'll talk about next steps
for artificial intelligence
at AB InBev.
I think we'll have some time,
quite a bit of time for making
an interactive at the end.
So let's definitely look
forward to some questions.
The history of innovation, we
think here in the Bay Area,
in Silicon Valley, that we
are the center of innovation.
But if you look back
more than 100 years ago,
the east coast in
the United States
was a major center
of innovation.
And we draw from that tradition.
You've probably heard the names
Alexander Bell, Thomas Edison,
powerhouses of invention
and innovations.
And Anheuser-Busch actually has
a very long history dating back
to the 1800s.
Our second brewery was
the Newark brewery.
And we were really excited
about that as a company
back then because our origins
in St. Lewis, going to Newark--
it was our second major brewery,
and it was just the first
in our global story.
We have a tradition
going back in Europe,
as the parent company, of also
hundreds and hundreds of years.
So today New Jersey
is the center
for what we call tech supply.
Tech supply is the technical arm
of our more than 350 breweries
around the world.
Tech supply is driving
digital transformation
of our supply chain.
And so some of the
things I want to call out
that we're trying to
embrace as a company
include making a brewery,
a connected brewery.
What does that mean?
That means everything from the
SCADA and industrial systems,
bringing them online, doing
it in a secure fashion,
collecting data
from industrial IOT,
and then leveraging that data
to make more smarter decisions
to make much more efficient
operations to get you
and me, the consumers,
the products
that we love in the
faster amount of time.
The Smart Brewery
Project is doing
things such as using AI
and analytics, for example,
to predict shifts in demand
from our consumers, seasonality
shifts.
In our mobile brewery
projects we're
doing things such as moving away
from really expensive custom
applications, like scanners,
and using everyday commodity
mobile phones that
can scan QR codes,
and integrating that in
with things like WeChat,
for example.
So we're running pilots
like that in China today.
And our goal is ultimately to
make each one of our breweries
a managed brewery.
So to be able to have the
people, the equipment,
the technology in place, so
that we can be more efficient
and we can have
linear operations.
So I'm going to dig in
to one such innovation,
we call it the Newark
Innovation using the K-Filter.
The image that you see on
the screen is of a K-Filter.
We're going to talk a little
bit more about what it does.
But in a nutshell,
it helps us ensure
beer is a consistent color
and a consistent taste.
The K-Filter project
started in late 2017
right here in the Bay Area.
Down in Mountain View we have an
office called The Beer Garage,
where I'm based.
And The Beer Garage is
our center of innovation.
We work with partners
such as Pluto7,
such as Google, and a
large ecosystem of partners
to look at all aspects
of our business,
whether it's industrial aspects,
supply chain, traditional tech
aspects, HR, as well as sales.
And we come together and
we try to look at, what
are the problems we have today?
And how can we solve
those problems?
So the theme back in November
was, let's look at tech supply
in particular and find some use
cases that we can innovate on.
So we invited a bunch
of our partners.
We invited Google.
And they actually
recommended Pluto7
after listening to what
we were trying to achieve
with our industrial processes.
We identified three use cases of
which the K-Filter optimization
was one of the use cases.
And we took that use case
after doing a lot of ideation
and building proof of
concepts to our leadership.
And the leadership
blessed these projects.
And then it was time to
really go to the business.
We're a decentralized
organization spread
around the world.
So we had to find, where
is the right place that we
can apply this technology?
The right place we can
apply this process?
And the people who would
be receptive to this sort
of a pilot.
So we zeroed in late 2018
on the Newark brewery
and started a
production pilot there.
So this is what the pilot
is attempting to achieve.
Previously, a brewmaster would
have to look at the output
from that big K-Filter,
that giant container
that you saw earlier, and based
on their experience, which
was very good, and based on
their understanding of what
that particular beer that
was flowing through-- like I
mentioned, we have 500 beers,
and they're interchangeable.
Different breweries might
be brewing different beers
on different runs.
And so based on
their experience,
based on the unique
characteristics of that beer,
they would have to
determine that this
is the right color
and the right taste
to be bottled and shipped.
Well, brewmasters are very good.
We were trying to improve
what they were doing.
And we were trying to do that
to save time and save money.
Switching those
filtering processes out
took a lot of time.
Having to replace
a filter earlier
before it was detected by
consumers could be expensive.
Switching it too late
means that we had product
that we had to throw away.
And so the K-Filter
project really
looked at the clarity
of the beer in advance
of a human being being able
to detect that we're deviating
from those two key criteria.
So how did how did we do that?
Well, first of all, we
spent a lot of time.
Luckily, a lot of
it was tasting beer.
And so we invited Pluto7
and Google Cloud team
to join us in Newark.
And they looked at
our beer processes.
They spent a lot of
time looking at, what
are the brewmasters seeing?
What are the inputs?
What are areas that
we can plug in?
How can we extract
data from the process?
Nothing was connected
at the time.
And Salil will wheel
talk a little bit more
about the details of that.
But before we get
into that, I want
to share a quick video
on how the project went.
So let's cue the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- AB InBev is one of
the largest brewing
companies in the entire world.
The key brands that we produce
are Budweiser, Bud Light,
and Stella Artois.
- Brewing is such
an old industry.
And we've used a lot of the same
technologies for the last 100
years.
And so we've started
to use technology
to digitally transform
our operations.
- Our innovation team at AB
InBev teams up with Google
and Pluto7 to find a way
to extend the life of each
K-Filter run, which is a process
where the beer has certain
particles that come
from fermentation,
and you have these filters that
are set up in which the beer
turbidity level, which
is how clear the beer is,
has to get below a
certain threshold.
So what you have is a multi
variable problem where when you
reach a certain threshold, the
machine has to be shut down.
It's a balancing
act because you have
to keep that turbidity
level below the required
amount for that brand.
- The K-Filter process is a very
manual process traditionally.
What we've done is take a
lot of the human error out
of that and automate and really
accelerate the decision making.
- The solution was to take
this Google Machine Learning
Engine, put in billions
of simulations,
look for trends
within that data for,
this can prolong the
life here, or there.
Not only does it
allow you longer
average runs but
there's energy savings,
and finally, there's
the beer itself,
which more uptime means you
can produce more as well as not
having to throw
out wasted brands.
- The value of working in
the partnership with Pluto7
is that they're scalable because
of the Google Cloud Platform.
So the learnings
we get from Newark
we can scale across breweries
across 126 countries.
And artificial intelligence
Pluto7 and Google Cloud
platform is a part of
this broader vision
to transform how we make
beer, and deliver it
faster in more
consistently higher quality
to our valued customer.
- Every opportunity we
have to be at the forefront
puts us in a position to
compete better, but also
prove that technology
like this can
be successful on an
industrial environment.
[END PLAYBACK]
SALIL AMONKAR:
Thank you, Khelan.
Well, are you guys awake now?
OK.
Just a few pointers.
I'll get into some
of the details.
We will leave room
for Q&A. And I have
some of our team members here.
So if you have any more
detailed questions,
which I will not explain--
I mean, if you want
more information,
feel free to ask the
questions after we
are done with the presentation.
One more point.
The gentleman you saw,
Adam, was supposed
to be on the stage
with us, with me now.
His flight, believe it or
not, had an emergency landing
in Chicago.
So Khelan here
graciously was available,
and he's also
involved in AB InBev,
and he agreed to
go up on the stage.
So we have the customer
instead of just
having me presenting to you.
So without further ado,
next slide, please.
KHELAN BHATT: Just click.
Here.
Use the clicker.
SALIL AMONKAR: So how does the
machine learning model work?
I think Adam spoke
about this in his video.
For those of you who
know machine learning,
this may be like you
know all about this.
But let's say there
are some people
in the audience who
perhaps are just
starting with machine learning.
The key thing is machine
learning is nothing but--
think about it as human
decision making on a chip.
The difference is a
chip does not get tired
and you can execute
multiple variable scenarios
at the way human beings
do at scale on a chip.
So what that enables
is we can now
consider the fact
that, when you're
talking about a production
process, a lot of inputs
are being collected.
This happens in most
manufacturing processes.
And in AB InBev, they also
collected a lot of data.
The reality is a lot of this
data never gets looked at.
Because most of the control
systems in place today,
they still look at
a few variables,
and that's how you
drive your operations.
With machine learning, what we
do is we go through a series
of data exploration, what
we call as data exploration
and analysis, which takes a
look at which of all these--
and in this case, we looked
at about 50 plus variables--
which of these have the direct
input to what is the output
that we are trying to achieve.
And in this case, the key output
that we are trying to achieve
are two things.
One is ensure that
we can figure out
when the filter will
have to be replaced,
so that the quality
of beer is maintained.
In this situation there is
another output that we also
have to watch out for, which
is, as a part of the filter
operation, there is something
called as a differential
of pressure that builds up.
And if the pressure exceeds
a certain threshold,
the filter automatically
goes into what
we call as a restart model.
So there are two things
that we look for,
which is the filter, what is
the differential pressure, as
an output measure,
or a variable.
And the second is
what is the prediction
for it going beyond the level.
And the second is the
measure of quality,
which is what in the beer
world is called stability.
The way this is done typically
today is a beermaster.
It's part art and part science.
So usually it's
the beermaster who
makes the guess to say,
OK, I think the filter that
has to be replaced.
So what we really enabled
is, take that decision making
from a human being and replicate
it in a machine learning brain.
And the way we did that
is what I just explained.
Take a look at the
input, figure out
what are the key
contributors to the output,
go through data
exploration, data analysis.
As a lot of who
have done machine
learning-- if you are in
the audience, will know,
80% of the time is all about
making sure that we actually
clean the data.
And then the remaining
time is making sure
that you can use that
to build a model.
So this is a summary
of how we did it.
And I'll go through
more details.
So the key thing,
as in any machine
learning, for a base
solution, is making sure
that you have the data.
I already said that there was--
in the production process,
or in a supply chain,
there's a lot of data that's
already been collected.
This just gives us schematic.
The idea here is to visually
show you what I just mentioned.
The key thresholds that we are
trying to predict, or control,
is the differential
pressure and the turbidity.
And what enabled
us to achieve this
is the fact that we
had a data collection
system, which was already at--
I mean, it was in place
at New Jersey brewery,
and as well as in
other breweries,
which collected the data
in 10 seconds interval.
And that data was available,
not only did they collect it,
it was actually available
in our database.
It was a Sybase database.
We took that data
and we loaded it
on the Google Cloud Platform.
And just to show you
this is a simpler--
in the interest of making
sure that we are maintaining
the confidentiality of
this competitive solution,
we're not going to show you
everything about the solution,
but I'm going to give you
enough information on how
a similar solution can be built.
This is a simple
architecture that we
used during the proof of concept
and the production pilot.
And I'll talk to
what advances we
are going to do next
in an example solution
that I will show, which
basically I showed you
where the data was
coming from-- we
loaded it into
Google Cloud Storage.
This is a result. Think
about it as just like a box.
You can store many
types of data on this.
We took that and--
for those of you who have done
this, they've used Data Lab.
Our team uses Data Lab,
which essentially enables
you to go through the process
of data cleaning, data
analysis, data
exploration, so that you
can select the algorithm.
You can actually then make sure
that you review the results.
After you look at the algorithm,
you feel that it is good,
you can then go
through the steps
of what we call as training
the model using data.
So the training is--
in layman's terms--
think about it, right?
If you have a human being
that learns, the way we learn
is through a series
of experiences
that we get from the time
we are born until adulthood.
Input data is nothing
but experiences
that you feed in a
machine learning model,
so that it can learn, these
are the outputs, this is what--
sorry-- these are
the inputs, this
was the output that happened.
So it builds that learning.
That's the process that we do,
what is called as training.
And then to verify that
the learning is accurate,
we do evaluation.
So all of that, those are
typical machine learning steps
that you might
have heard already.
We did that using Data Lab.
We use TensorFlow, a deep
learning neural network.
We used a combinational model
here, a classification model
to make sure that we can
predict when the filter was not
good enough.
And we also had to do some
time series element to it,
because since you
are predicting,
you need it to do the prediction
as to-- that is a time series
problem.
So we used a combinational model
and we loaded the process data
for reference in BigQuery.
In this scenario,
it was enough for us
to give the indicator
to the production
people on a weekly basis, so
that they could monitor what
were the elements that they
had to review and change
to maintain--
making sure that the filter
was-- the life of the filter
was known, and then extended.
So the key thing--
this is the key thing that I
want everybody to understand.
Most of the times, when human
beings look at a process,
and even with regular
statistical base process
control, you only are
monitoring certain elements,
and those, whatever you
monitor is what you get.
Using machine learning,
there are three key learnings
that were completely
counterintuitive that
came about in the joint work
that we did with AB InBev.
One was-- the traditional
approach was-- the thought
process was bodyfeed being
one of the-- bodyfeed
is the term that is
used in the industry
for the measure of additive
that is added to the filter
to filter the beer.
The thought process was,
if we add that slowly,
because it's a costly
material, it will be better.
Guess what, the data showed,
and the machine learning model
showed that you, actually,
if you fed the bodyfeed
at a higher rate
in the beginning,
just for a shorter period of
time, that was more helpful.
This was something that even
the production brewmaster said,
wow, I would have
never figured this out.
The second thing was
the fact that, OK,
you have to avoid fluctuations.
So they were trying to fluctuate
the bodyfeed in the interest
of, again, trying to save.
It actually was countering
to do, and the data showed--
and it was brewing--
I'll show you the
results shortly--
that keeping the fluctuations
less and keeping it
steady state was actually
more helpful to prolonging
the life of the filter
as well as maintaining
the quality of the filter.
Thirdly, making sure
that your bodyfeed
was optimized to the lowest
level at 30 pounds per hour
actually helped.
And they were not keeping
it at 30 pounds per hour.
They were actually keeping
it at a higher level.
So, again, now, that
was a direct correlation
to the cost savings.
So net-net is-- these
are some examples
that I wanted to point out.
The net-net is-- these
are the results that
actually were observed
from the production pilot.
We did the production
pilot on two lines
in the New Jersey brewery.
In the one line, we got an
improvement of about 44%.
And this is comparing
the amount of runs
when you said start
and stop of the filter
before we did that change
and after we did the change.
In the second line,
we actually saw
that the production
improvement was much more
than the first line.
And the differences
we attributed
was because they were--
on the second line
there were more opportunities
where the production
people were not following
a few standards,
so that accounted
for the distribution.
In any case, a 44%
improvement was way more
than what we expected
that we started with.
So as a result of
this now, we have--
in fact, Adam, who is not
here, just between him and us,
we now have finalized
the other locations
that we are going to
deploy this solution to,
now that the production
results are out
and it looks like it
is a good thing to do.
And so what I want to talk about
next is a quick recap of what
the solution was, which,
again, the idea is to make sure
that you take data,
you process the data,
you select the right
inputs, know the outputs
that you are pursuing,
and making sure
that you do the model, not only
do you do a proof of concept
but then you do a
production pilot.
The learnings from
the production pilot,
as we observed,
were huge in terms
of making sure that
now we understand
how we will deploy it
in multiple breweries,
as an example.
So like I said, I cannot
show the actual solutions.
It's a competitive
advantage to my customer.
What I'm going to do
now is show a solution--
and by the way,
this solution, we
are going to put
the entire solution
available to all of you on
AI Hub, which Google just
announced.
It will be available
in about a month.
The solution is all ready.
We have not been able
to put it because Google
has to open the door to us
to put it on the AI Hub.
But I'm going to show you
snippets of that solution.
And my team is
here also with me.
If you are interested
in knowing more details,
feel free to talk to us
after this presentation.
So just to showcase to you--
I'm going to showcase
a genetic solution that
will show how you can--
for example, if temperature
is one of the variables,
and temperature is
one of the variables
that matter in a
brewing process,
how you can monitor it
and proactively predict
failures that could
impact the temperature.
So this is a single variable
solution that we have--
like I said, the full solution,
including the entire work
that was done by our team,
will be available in AI Hub.
And that's what I want to
quickly walk you guys through.
So before I go into the
details of the solution,
here is the visual.
What this shows you is--
it will look at
how, in this case,
the temperature control
at the end of the day
is dependent on
basically two things, how
you put the heat back
in the controlled area,
or you take heat out
of the controlled area,
and that is dependent
on basically
the ambient temperature,
as it is noted.
So the machinery
that controls this,
either you are having a heat
exchanger taking heat out,
or you are having
a fan blower system
that is in a heating element
that is putting heat back in.
So what this shows
actually is that--
how you can use data from
past and use that to predict
when the failures will happen.
And then you can put
in safety controls,
so that before your temperature
variation becomes too much,
you can actually
take care of it.
Or in this situation, if there
is a particular fan blower
part that, for
example, will fail,
you can know about
it in advance,
so that you can take care of
it before it actually happens.
Now, what I would
also like to do
is go and showcase
to you a sample code,
and also talk about
how we are going
to approach this
solution going forward,
which I'll talk about how we
are going to leverage Kubeflow
and that concept and
technology to help
make sure that we can
deploy this solution
to multiple breweries.
So we are going to
use the concept.
If I can have the switch
over to my laptop, please.
Thank you.
So while it is coming up,
and you can see here-- there.
Thank you.
This is an example
of what I mentioned,
how a typical machine
learning model is developed.
So what I'm going to showcase
to you is, in this solution,
what we have done is we
take this entire process
of making sure that data,
which is your existing data,
and you are continuously taking
additional data, because that's
what you have to do--
you're using that data
to make the model learn.
So first of all, taking
the data, processing it,
you are to use that
to train the model,
you will do the evaluation,
and then deploy the new model,
and then use it to
make prediction.
So all of these steps that
I described, we actually--
some of it is what
I'm showing you.
As some people who are dealing
with either data science
or machine learning, this
will be very familiar.
The first part is
making sure that you
have all the libraries loaded.
Then you are preparing
the Google Storage
to receive the
data that you need.
And then we take
that data, make sure
that the data
pre-processing is done.
Then we take that data, and
now we are invoking the model.
And the model is
then being trained.
And after the training,
we do the evaluation.
And after the
evaluation is done,
we then deploy the model
back onto the GCM LE.
And so this entire process--
I'm just showing you a snippet.
This whole thing is
like a Docker image.
And there's a series
of Docker images
that forms part of
the Kubleflow, which
I'm going to talk
about and show you
the architectural result next.
And I mentioned the
fact that we are
going to put the entire
solution that will
be available to all of you.
This is, not only are
we putting the solution,
we are going to give
step by step instructions
on how you can use
this genetic solution.
And if you just take this
in a guide and go through it
step by step, you can
actually take our solution
that we will put on AI Hub, take
your own data, play with it,
experiment with it, use it.
Like I said, this is a subset,
a very genetic solution
that shows how you can
control one variable.
Like this, we are also
deploying two other solutions.
This is what we call
as a part of Supply ML.
And then we are also--
in addition to this,
we are also deploying
to the public solutions
around marketing and sales,
as an example.
Now, going back to--
with that, I would like to go
back to the main presentation.
And I talked about the fact that
preparing for the deployment
to multiple breweries,
part of that will need--
part of it will
need using Kubeflow
to ensure that we can
consistently-- now that we have
the model proven, how do
we take that and seamlessly
keep deploying those models
with different locations of Ab
InBev?
However, noting that there
might be some changes in how
the data is collected,
or the data actually
exists in multiple breweries.
So this is the architecture.
Again, for more
detailed discussion
on this architecture, we
can have the discussion
after the main presentation.
What it is just showing
is how you take the steps.
The steps that you did
around developing the model.
And now you do this with
a series of Kubeflows,
and you keep deploying
it in multiple locations,
or you keep deploying
iterations of the model
as new and newer models
are trained and evaluated
to do the prediction.
This is a generic slide.
This basically
shows the advantage
of using Kubeflow versus
how we had to do it before.
What you have to do if you don't
use Kubeflow is go through all
of the series of steps, and then
every time you have to deploy,
you still need the
experts, who are
the data scientist and
the data engineers,
doing the steps in the red.
So now the advantage is, once
the whole solution is actually
done, all we need is basically
just a software engineer who
can use Kubeflow and
deploy it without invoking
the time of the data scientist
or the data engineer.
This is just a visual.
For those of you who are
already using Kubeflow,
this will be familiar.
The bottom line, think
about it this way,
in a very simplistic manner,
Kubeflow is nothing but--
if I were to simplify it,
you set up a cluster once,
that's a one time setup,
that cluster using GKE
is what you use then to
keep deploying pipelines,
and these pipelines are
nothing but Docker containers
where your set of either
solution or machine learning
algorithms are containerized
and then deployed, so that it
becomes a seamless deployment.
So you can start with
a master and then
you can have
multiple deployments
in multiple locations
as required.
A lot of you who are
working with Kubeflow
already know this.
So, again, I'm not going to
go through that detail here.
But my team is available if you
have questions around the same.
So with that, we
wanted to give you guys
a flavor of what the technology
was involved, how did we do it.
I would like to turn
it back to Khelan
to walk you through
what does he, Adam,
and the rest of
the AB InBev team
see now that they have seen the
success of using Google Cloud
Platform and machine
learning and AI
to really help solve a
real business use case.
Over to you, Khelan.
KHELAN BHATT: Yeah.
I think we're going to automate
our jobs away pretty soon.
So I'm looking forward to that.
More time to drink beer.
No, we're really
excited by the results
of the K-Filter optimization
production pilot.
And so we're trying to look at
where else in our supply chain
can we really look
at applying some
of these techniques, partnering
with Google Cloud, with Pluto.
So a couple of things we've
identified-- so on this
screen you'll kind of
see four different areas.
But in the kilning process,
that's where we're heating--
we're applying a lot of dry
heat to remove excess moisture
and be able to move to the
next steps in the process.
On the top right here,
the yeast separation,
there's things that we're
looking at running pilots.
Bottom right, in terms
of mashing control, where
we release the sugars
that have been created.
And then on the bottom
left here, reverse osmosis.
We're looking at how can we
save the water and electricity
involved in these
processes, so to meet some
of our sustainability goals.
So there's a lot of places
within the supply chain,
within our brewery
environment that we can apply.
But even taking a step further
back, there is a lot of things
that we can do outside of
justice supply chain, outside
of the brewery process.
And I'd say we're
really just down here
on the connected brewery side.
We're bringing the
breweries online.
We're bringing the data that
was previously siloed, maybe
in those systems, in
the Sybase database,
and we're bringing
it into the cloud.
We already have other
initiatives within our company
where we're building data lakes.
And so it's all about moving
from improving productivity
on one component, on one
part of the production line,
to other aspects of
the production line,
to other breweries.
If Adam were here, he would--
I think he would
be beaming about,
where are we going to expand?
Just the K-Filter project next.
And speaking as somebody who
works on the infrastructure
side, on the way
that we get data
securely from our
breweries to the cloud,
I know that I am really
excited about being
able to enable some of these
things and move upwards
as we look at, how do we improve
productivity at a brewery
level, how our business
units, which we call zones,
are performing.
Here in North America
we're particularly
lucky that we've made
lots of investments
in technology and automation.
But if you imagine
a company like ours,
we have more than 350
breweries around the world,
some zones have under-invested.
There's a lot of
legacy infrastructure.
There's a lot of--
like I said earlier, the margins
are very low in those markets.
If you charge what you
charge for a beer in places--
San Francisco-- maybe in parts
of Asia and parts of Africa,
nobody's going to buy that beer.
And so just improving that
efficiency on its own level
is really exciting for us.
And ultimately, we want to get
to the level of where we're not
just improving the supply chain,
we're not just reducing costs,
but we're reacting faster.
And so what that really means
is, here in Mountain View,
in The Beer Garage, we're
looking at innovations
being able to give you,
the consumers, the ability
to brew beer, maybe, at home
using something like K Cups.
And so there's tie ups that
we're working on there.
Being able to do innovations
that leverage block chain
technologies that can
let you understand,
where did your beer come from?
I can pick up a bottle of wine
pretty much from any winery
and see who was--
what grape it was, what year
it was, where it was produced.
But today, if I pick
up a bottle of beer,
I don't have that information.
And so being able to unlock
some of that information
in our supply chain will give us
a closer connection to the beer
we drink in a similar fashion.
So that's just a roadmap.
And I'm happy to
talk more offline
about any of these things.
Leading in-- you want to talk
a little bit about outside
of the beer industry,
what do you see?
SALIL AMONKAR: Sure.
So I'm very happy that Khelan
is talking about the brewery
of the future.
One of the things
that's very close to me
as an industry expert
in manufacturing,
I keep hearing a lot of the
customers talking about it,
is Manufacturing 4.0, or
they call it Industry 4.0.
Don't worry about the buzzword.
More important is, what
does it represent, right?
So to simplify it, these
had three generations
of key changes that changed
the way manufacturing was done.
First was the invention
of the steam engine
and the steam power that led
to the first manufacturing
evolution.
Then the whole concept of
mass production that was
pioneered by Henry
Ford, that raised--
basically improved the cost
and made a lot of the products
accessible to the consumer.
Then we had the
computer-aided innovation.
And now finally, with
AI, cloud computing,
and IOT coming together
we are on the cusp
of the next great innovation
around manufacturing, which you
will hear is Manufacturing 4.0.
That's what it is.
I just wanted to make sure
that everybody understood that.
And then here is
what that means.
For example, in a real life
scenario-- in this case,
I'm giving an example
since Khelan showcased
to you what they are thinking
about from the brewery
of future.
How does that impact the
supply chain of a future,
in this case, for
a beer company?
So what is the impact?
So how you can take everything
right from the beginning
all the way with
intelligence, so that you--
actually, it is-- think about
it as AI helping human beings,
not replacing human beings,
but helping human beings make
things better.
And then, finally, I would
like to thank all of you.
One thing I'm not sure, Khelan,
if we mentioned to the team,
that the project that we did
was the finalist for the supply
chain Gartner--
sorry-- Gartner supply chain
award for ROI and innovation.
And we were the finalists.
The other five companies were
Amazon, Dell, Lenovo, Merck,
and Levi's.
So just wanted to end
the note with that.
KHELAN BHATT: Never
heard of those guys.
[LAUGHTER]
SALIL AMONKAR: So it's
a great partnership.
I'm happy to have the customer
talk about how they found this
very useful, how they're
leveraging here, and more
importantly, how do they see
the potential of Google Cloud
Platform, and help them
achieve their strategy
of the brewery of the future.
[MUSIC PLAYING]